i believe it is the artist's
responsibility
to lead people into hell
but i also believe it's important to
lead the way out
[Music]
we are in a renaissance of documentary
people are realizing that
there is as much drama in what is and
what was
as anything that the human imagination
dreams of
and you have the added advantage of it
being true
in order to be a good director you have
to be able to tolerate
contradiction there's no objective truth
this is human experience we see things
from different perspectives
and that's okay it's really important
that history not be
distilled to sort of the great men
theory
all of those people that are famous
don't do the fighting and the dying
the best history is the place where
so-called ordinary people exist
you want to use everything at your
disposal
to activate your audience's imagination
the cannon firing troops tramping
back cracking there are a million
things that you can do that you have to
do until you go whoa that's working
we find ourselves in one of the most
challenging moments in the history of
the united states
the role of the filmmaker then becomes
even more important
and more urgent if you've got that thing
that is burning inside you
saying i have to do this
now we can begin to talk about how you
start
i'm ken burns and this is my master
class
you